in nigeria authorities are searching for
17 people who've been kidnapped the
abduction took place in the capital city
abuja one woman known as sufjan posted a
message on twitter stating that she had
been taken by men disguised as police
officers along with 16 other women
including three who are pregnant
while kidnappings for ransom are not
uncommon in nigeria the capital is
normally safe
well for more on this story i'm joined
now by dw correspondent owais uh idris
in the nigerian capital abuja who is
abductions taking place in broad
daylight now in abuja how are people
there reacting to that
well it's a reaction of anger and
frustration by many nigerians especially
on the social media where this abduction
was reported by one the victim who
tweeted and seek for help telling
nigerians to help her nigerian tourists
to help her so people are angry that the
police up till now they are unable to
rescue the victim having
make a broadcast on her twitter handle
and on her facebook sharing her own
location they are saying why is it
taking so long to rescue these people
and this thing happened in abuja which
is very rare to see
large people being abducted in this
capital
you mentioned that at least one of those
who've been abducted one of the women
has used her mobile phone to reach out
has
the fact that the abductees are using
their mobile phones apparently helping
the police to find them
well in some way it has because the
police in one of their actions said they
have contacted the families of the
victims and they are making progress in
trying to rescue them this is this
doesn't happen before because it takes
long to even
wait and hear until the abductors called
using any of the mobile phones but now
that the location has been shared the
police said they are using the location
shared by the victim to trust them and
they contacted even the families and
there is progress
lewis what do these kidnappings say
about security and stability in nigeria
well it explained the growing insecurity
in nigeria especially which has to do
with abductions and kidnappings although
it has become more or less a daily
affair in the southwest in the northwest
western part of nigeria and you know
abuja
is surrounded by states that are having
these problems kaduna nasarawa niger and
kogi
most of these places there are
abductions going on but making a road
into the capital city
although is not the first time was the
first time that large number of people
have been taken by these abductors it
tells a lot about the insecurity it
sends a lot of fear in the minds of
nigerians although the authorities kept
saying that we are doing our best you
should go with your normal businesses
because just two weeks back and instead
was attacked when people went to say no
it was abduction the police said no it
was armed robbery and even those who
live there come out to deny a kind of
trying to kill the story so it tells
about the growing insecurity in
nigeria's
capital abuja and in the country because
this is where it's supposed to be
secured this is where the president
recites
luis thank you very much uh that was our
correspondent ue idris in abuja
thank you
you